what's happened in reject nation I'm
Greg Alba then I'm John Humphrey we are
gonna be doing another gene jeter joint
here if you're a loyal follower of this
channel you've probably seen our genes
eater reactions you see one of our top
reward tiers over our patreon page is
whatever video you request we must do
and put up on youtubes and gene and all
the months he's been pledged only
request that we check out his videos I
wonder if he's trying to promote himself
I don't know man I wouldn't put it past
him though but who knows who knows and
he's got a crazy Instagram with hot ass
babes on there sometimes you get some
lovely ladies featured here he's an
artist for sure who really likes to
experiment and has a strange way of
storytelling and I think this is one of
his monologues but I think there's a
performer in front of the camera for
this one it's called cafeteria food on
Fridays this lady named Brooke Dylan
Stein is performing this monologue he
wrote let's listen to it
[Music]
because if you're lucky
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is that footage in the actual egg a
movie or is that just trailer
manipulation no no that's in the that's
the whole finale right there Oh what
Thanos was really his plan was the whole
time is he's just like really jealous of
every pizza so he figures if he wipes
out half the universe there will be that
half of the pizza and milks for him that
makes so much more sense now there's
actually a flashback scene of young
Thanos you know like in a high school
cafeteria or whatever like just trying
to get some pizza I'm like and push down
like all the kids dump their milk on top
of him and call him an idiot and a [ __ ]
and stuff like that
mm-hmm so that's why he is the way he is
this is actually crucial this is a
spoiler yeah more I do if you want to
keep going we can keep going though she
also maybe Patty's in the strawberry I
know which that is trailer manipulation
because you know like think about it
what a weird combination of food to eat
a beef patty with nothing and some
strawberry milk and so that's definitely
an intentional mislead probably having
something to do with the quantum realm
and new characters they want to bring in
you know Captain Marvel's involvement
this makes a lot more you want to keep
going
I've okay I've got tons of lore I dunno
I know I know it's all gonna be gold I
like old ties point I can tell oh great
I'm so glad I set you up for that bit
hey cut it whenever you like nope it's
the hold things in there now uh yeah
this is a really interesting monologue
it did you know the second the whole
thing about pizza got brought up I did
go back to my mind like when I went to
cafeteria and junior high
in elementary school it was pizza she's
your pepperoni were the two choices we
got all the other experiences she's
talking about like what [ __ ] school
did she go - or did Jean go - they write
this Jean often draws from some
real-life inspiration whether something
he experienced something he heard from
someone something he write about he
often draws from something that is real
the end game script the end game script
oh you got more callback oh you only
needed 30 more seconds you got to call
back in there it's so specific and so
detailed that I have a difficult time
imagining that this is not drawn from
some real-life thing he either
experienced himself growing up I don't
know and the west coast of the school we
went to in high school did you have any
of this pocketing milk experience that
people are talking about because people
were weird not exactly I mean the thing
is this video definitely did take me
back to the old days you know and the
cafeteria and the different lunches we
would have each day and there were days
that were like more desirable than
others when they would bring in like
hamburgers reah pizza or something like
that
other days yeah man and so I do remember
these sort of frenzy and excitement over
like a special lunch day but what I
don't remember is you have people like
robbing each other of pizza or milk or
like fiendishly like the thing is it's
like penguins with rock so they gather
that the second you step away a penguin
will grab that rock Disneynature go
watch that movie that's what this is
really about is to promote the movie
penguins but I wondered partway through
if maybe this is based on an experience
from like we we didn't go to his big of
a school and so I wondering if maybe
like in a public elementary or junior
high I'm wondering what level of school
this was supposed to come from because
maybe with so many people around maybe
there isn't quite as much of enough for
everyone fair cuz I got the sense of
when we went to school things were
contained and so they could just like
order enough and it was fine you know
yeah you would only have to worry about
getting jacked if you didn't buy lunch
at all that yeah you brought your own or
some
like that would you think of her
performance I thought she was nice I
thought she was endearing you know she
seemed to speak with some kind of level
of believable look she Perry hasn't seem
like she's in school though no no that's
why I was wondering she look like she
was like 21 like is this happening to
you now because that's a problem I mean
yes not how adults should be hey Brooke
Dylan Stein apparently is a working
actress so let's look her up and see if
her age is available to find out nope
that's a smart thing actually knowing
these photos she looks really young yeah
never mind I take that back oh wait now
she looks like it actually all these
photos of her on ITV yeah yeah I thought
she did a really great job really
capture that spirit of being in eighth
grade yeah well then I don't know why
you've ever seen 8th grades on 8th grade
this could be high school right trailer
for the movie yeah it could be high
school Ella liked it but - I was still
wondering because I don't know I feel
like people's behaviors about special
lunches change Oman over time and age
rapidly from elementary junior high to
high school it's like people definitely
didn't aggressively rob each other of
lunches it wasn't for me when did you
hire Brooke Dillon Stein was this before
she started booking stuff on like
Pharaoh's bread and facts of life or was
this when she just needed something to
do and you know to get experience and
get work and be on camera just he did I
could hear you flip it it feels like an
audition tape in some ways yeah I could
hear between the jump cuts
you probably G behind the camera
flipping the page this evening I almost
feel like a like a taped monologue for
something yeah yeah I get that
impression but still it's interesting
monologue it seemed that I really draw
from something that was very real life I
enjoyed it yeah guys you should go check
out more jeans videos there's stuff a
Jean joint to have yourself a jean Athan
as I like to call it he's a really
really kind guy him and I talk a lot
he's a very deep person as well someone
with a lot of emotional integrity and
emotional understanding and is wildly
creative yeah it's a put it bluntly he's
just a weird person he's very strange
and I like strange
I like weird never died don't know about
in person but definitely through the
distance between New York and LA I think
it's very appropriate would I FaceTime
him maybe would I go to lunch with him
he'd probably spit on my food only to
keep you from stealing his would I
message him on patreon weekly no no gene
you're a great guy thanks for all the
support buddy you're a wonderful dude
and please go check out more of this
guy's content there's a wide variety of
it's not just this it's a whole bunch of
stuff yeah maybe one day he'll direct
one of our sketches that that will be a
very uncommon for some very attractive
female yes subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification Belger
check out more of Jenny's videos